bébé du centre-sud ce n'est pas un jeu et je
peux t'apprendre à te battre mais parfois
tes meilleures armes sont tes mots tu as
jamais pensé que je me rapprochais d'un
vagin jusqu'à ce que j'aie au moins 10 ans nous avons
commencé ce gymnase pour garder les enfants hors des
rues
nous  Je vais bien, ne laissez pas la version bêta se
construire, alors écoutez-moi et oncle Lee, sommes-
nous ici pour vol de banque, combien de
millions de dollars l'argent est dans le mur
dans ce flophouse au sous-sol, que
se passe-t-il, je vais l'avoir en rejoignant  la
fraternité salutations messieurs je suis ici
pour me précipiter j'ai un nom parfait pour s'adapter à la
paternité C fermez buttersworth votre
gage maître je suis sur le point de voir qui a
ce qu'il faut les blancs ils sont
terrifiés d'être appelés racistes première
chose que vous êtes des esclaves  va faire à Corning,
je ne suis pas sûr que nous devrions appeler l'engagement
des esclaves cette année n'est-il pas plus raciste
de changer nos traditions simplement parce que nous
avons un endroit noir Je suis tellement content que nous ayons
enfin cette discussion
oncle Lee y  'tous ont mon argent ouais de l'argent non
je veux dire sh  Nous aimons mes photos
sur Instagram tard dans la nuit pourquoi vous
n'étiez pas en robes Klan non notre fraternité
est en fait antérieure au plan de plus d'une
décennie alors pourquoi portent-ils nos robes
ouais vous portez tous des robes Klan
c'est super déroutant d'être un  homme blanc
dans la société d'aujourd'hui ok tous les noirs
j'ai amené le bus oh mon dieu
comment tu faisais ça ce n'est pas ce à quoi ça
ressemble on dirait que tu t'es fait
prendre dans des courses pour dix personnes
eh bien alors c'est exactement à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique  ]
donc je vais organiser des galas de charité à venir, nous
allons faire de vous le commissaire-priseur maintenant mon
arrière arrière arrière arrière grand-père
aimerait m'entendre dire ça sortez votre facture les
gens parce que nous achetons des blancs aujourd'hui
[Musique]